dancing with the star pro Witney Carson  is officially a married woman the 22  year old dancer said I do to her high  school sweetheart Carson McAllister on  New Year's Day  Carson's rep confirmed to ET that the  pair exchanged vows in a beautiful  three-part ceremony near Salt Lake City  Utah celebrity wedding planner Michael  Russo organized the couple's big day the  bride wore a stunning Rivini gown while  her bridesmaids including fellow dance  pros Emma Slater Lindsey Arnold of  gritty cherry and Jenna Johnson dawned  on Saleh guests shared snaps from the  lavish reception using the hashtag  McAllister wedding 2016 dancing the  night away with family and friends  seemed to be the highlight of the  evening the newlyweds announced their  engagement in October and Whitney gushed  about her groom writing finally get to  be with my love forever and all eternity